hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
carnivore I know it's been a while I've
kind of had other projects that I've
been doing but I've always meant to get
back to carnival because I wanted to
beat it considering it's one of the few
that I have not beaten yet I think I've
beaten pretty much every other one
besides this so I'm the [ __ ] and the
Christmas special but I may not visit
that Santa is too terrifying okay so
I've kind of reviewed a bit of the
location so I'm going to try to make
this as quick as possible because
slender is a son of a [ __ ] here's an
a-hole I can't believe that there's one
near the original location if not then I
will be screwed but I do know that
there's a bowtie or a pair of booties I
do not know something along the lines of
okay it's now on the truck ergo it is
over ha ha ha number one I think there
are a pair of booties now that I'm
looking at them more closely and Slendy
it's gonna be a pain in the ass like he
always is so screw you everything you
care about mister man mister Slendy man
and it's probably one out on the hello I
thank you I'll take that and I believe
that there's probably something out in
the woods here I think I've tried to
look up there I have not been able to
find like a map with the actual
locations there doesn't seem to be
anything out here seem to be wasting my
time yeah I can't find like a map with
the page locations which is helping me
beat the other one why is it that to get
you noise that was the get you noise he
didn't get me
go evolve is that something no that's
electrical box what is that there where
is he shove my fist up his butt what was
that who's squealing who's squealing
there tires
go away sled yeah oh yeah - give me a
damn chance ok no thank you I do not
want any hot I'm so screwed
I thought I knew where some of these
things were and I do not and it's so
easy to miss them cut everything looks
the same job I hear you out there I got
my volume turned up again your voices in
the distance nothing really
oh god damn there's nothing out here
that's nothing no but hey I'm all alone
I'm alone I'm alone in the woods or in
the carnival anybody else listen - here
come the mommies I like carnal carnival
song it's happy and about something
better than being stalked in the woods
by Slendy it's gotta be one this these
woods out here for a reason out here you
gotta get it okay thank you
ah Lizabeth this wall here makes no
sense there's so many buildings Lily got
2 and I got nothing nothing to nobody
nobody there's nothing in these woods
he's woods are a sham I felt more of my
other trice in this supposedly one where
I knew where I was going I know there's
something in the bathroom she's going
there not knowing in this one none this
one either this is a ladies restroom ha
ha ha
evidence ever danced
I like these kids ah damn what is he
right there
go away you [ __ ] come on shove my fist
up your ass
actually I'm not gonna do that
much like you don't have a face I bet
you don't have a rectum rectum
damn near killed um I'm out of sprint up
and Javan the shift button too much okay
let's just calmly and collectively ah
there's something on the page out here
oh there's actually a page on the wound
woods what we're done boy the unexpected
error popped up in a completely
different program ha ha I'm still going
strong I think oh don't you start that
with me I'll don't you shut damn up with
that noise ok so dead end here funny man
let's see you over there I can't sprint
very much more
the Penan just about every one of these
buildings where the Frick is it what am
I even looking for how no looking for my
doom go away go away nothing nobody
nothing he's right there
he dare stop it you [ __ ] I will Jack
slap you get away go away I see you ah
come on I made almost a complete circle
now I've made a complete circle and I
have found nothing a back at the place
with the booties is that some that's now
time that's cotton candy that is not
evidence there's evidence of a delicious
tasty treat but not evidence of what I'm
looking for oh it's gotta be something
like a teddy bear maybe look that I see
a glowing machine I just a vending
machine troll that Ching machine not
something that I need yes I died
okay all right okay I've got a badge
where is that stupid machine Bubba cool
oh all right
oh come on hey buddy hi friend oh but
you stay the Frick and frack over there
Jesus I've been in all of these if I
pass them up and you guys have seen it
you're all laughing at me I am going to
be very upset at the end of this game
I'm going to be very upset I've only got
five it's friggin hard oh no how to beat
it don't know oh no I don't know is this
evidence ashtray evidence I don't know
there's nothing here I've gone in a big
circle I don't know where I'm going pull
over I thought I knew I thought I knew
the locations I hate going back in this
letter yes
I know I thought I had it how I'm went
in there with confidence and they switch
all the places around okay I'm done
screw that screw that anyway so thank
you all some patrol watching if you know
if you know like of a map or something
that I could actually beat this let me
know send me an email or something oh no
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos soon I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video